français apprennent que le prix du gaz
va de nouveau augmenté de 12,6 pour cent
au 1er octobre soit depuis deux ans une
hausse record de près de 58%
c
[Musique]
à cette hausse du gaz vient s'ajouter la
hausse du prix de l'électricité et des
carburants il ya désormais urgence à
agir car les français vont voir leur
pouvoir d'achat fortement s'éroder avec
le coût croissant des énergies en
particulier les plus précaires en 2020
nous vous avions déjà alerté sur
l'insuffisance du chèque énergie vous
proposé une revalorisation de 100 euros
c'est peu et c'est bien tardive d'autant
que les taxes sur les carburants et
l'énergie vont rapporter cette année
beaucoup à l'état et nous le savons tous
[Musique]
la vraie question de fond qui se pose
c'est comment concilier la poursuite de
la relance de l'économie et enfin
l'urgence du court terme qui nous impose
de nous préoccuper du quotidien des
français
c
[Musique]
nous sommes un des rares et du monde
dans lequel le pouvoir d'achat n'a pas
reculé pendant la crise qu vide en
attendant nous faisons jouer la
solidarité nationale avec le chèque
énergie et les 100 euros supplémentaires
que nous la zale ont versé à 5 8
millions de ménages d'ici à la fin de
l'année
[Musique]
j'ai annoncé il ya quelques semaines
pour prendre effet en décembre un chèque
énergie exceptionnelle s'ajoutant à
celui que nous avions créé qui sera
versé en janvier mais vous avez raison
cela ne suffit pas j'ai donc demandé aux
services d'étudier des actions
complémentaires qui seront qui seront
présentés dans les tout prochains jours
[Musique]